halos forage is a powerful tool for
making custom maps and game modes if
you're a fan of both Master Chief's
adventures and the Star Wars universe
you're in for a treat thanks to xbox
live user captain direwolf you can play
the Boonta Eve pod race in halo 5
Guardians captain direwolf has built
replicas of Anna Canon sebulba's
podracers and the whole setup is
complemented by stadium seating and
Jabba's tower there's no way to actually
declare a winner so you'll have to use
the honor system if you race your
friends and if things get dangerous
you'll respond in a cage overlooking the
racetrack where you can fire a battle
rifle from above all told this is one of
the best tale of five forge maps we've
seen since the creation tools released
back in November we've seen plenty of
fantastic custom maps in halo 5
hopefully this one has inspired you to
create one of your own if not you can
always catch up with all the latest halo
news at gamespot maybe something will
catch your eye